good morning everyone
a little early for me but that's okay no
that's not - about 10:20 that's not bad
everyone enjoyed the party last night I
did I found out had queso on my my
little badge so I wear it with honor now
so my name is Jimmy you can find me on
twitter @ @j Bogart's all the slides and
presentation materials pretty much
anything I do is on github so you can
find that at github comm /j Bogart and I
blog on Jimmy Bogart calm
I used to blog in another site Lowe's
techies you can still find a lot of my
post there and there's some other junk
about me for my day job I work at a
consulting company out of Austin Texas
called head spring and I usually for my
just my daily work I build systems for
customers build custom systems for
customers and a lot of what this talk is
about is an experience where that a
customer I had in the last six months or
so so we had a customer a manufacturing
customer which means of course there
were an enterprise customer and they
wanted to move to micro services like
you do right like everyone everyone is
doing about doing microsomes that
services now then you should just quit
right that's what everyone's going to so
part of moving to moving to micro
services was they had a they had a new
partner they had acquired who's
manufacturing model was completely
different than what they were doing
today so they looked at their existing
system and said how can we incorporate
this different kind of manufacturing
into this existing system well they
couldn't so this said ok we'll build a
little system to the side that will
integrate somewhat what caught a micro
service because why the hell not I don't
agree with the existing system
now the DBAs got a got a hole got got
our heard about this and said what are
you doing we can't put that other
manufacturing system the side has to go
into this this centralized database for
everything is supposed to be so long
story short they cut out the DBAs from
the entire conversation and just said
right we're going to build this on top
of MongoDB because again micro services
[ __ ] to be you have to do them together
they just go together well
as time progressed they realized that
they needed to get the they needed to
get some of the more advanced features
out of MongoDB and then they went to the
website to see okay looks like those
aren't included out of the box in the
free version how much does the
Enterprise version cost well it turns
out the Enterprise version of MongoDB is
actually more expensive than the
Enterprise version of sequel server so
they said oh we've put ourselves into a
bind here that we have this suit we we
needed these more advanced features and
it's really expensive what do we do
well they wind up doing is saving money
by actually going to Azure cosmos TV so
what is Azure cosmos TV now I'm trying
to keep some of the marketing fluff out
of here but there are some specific
things in Azure cosmos to me that set it
apart from other kinds of no sequel
databases so as your cosmos DB is a
globally distributed that's important if
you need that kind of scale multi-model
database service so the idea is that I'm
not just having some kind of document
database I'm running locally and then I
need to put it in the cloud it's that I
have some kind of system application it
needs to have global reach across the
entire world and so for this
manufacturing company they didn't need
that because they had things like
inventory and orders they were managed
in a global a global ERP system and they
need to be able to communicate with that
and so they had all of their different
orders flowing through all their
different manufacturing facilities
worldwide and so they needed this kind
of global reach and global scale now the
second interesting part is the multi
model part and this is the part of the
kind of it's kind of weird at first
because I don't really think of a
database as having different models and
different querying capabilities but the
way that either cosmos DB is engineered
it allows it to support different kinds
of models and different kind of data
structures and different kind of
querying api's on top of it so there are
five ones they have today and they say
there there are more to come now one
thing I should caveat here is that you
have to pick this up front you can't mix
models you can't do something like a
graph database and a document database
together when you're creating a new
resource in Azure you do have to pick
this up front so just pick the right one
I guess know what you're creating I
haven't seen this to be a problem in
actual practice but it is something to
keep in mind
so the
models they do support one of the first
ones a kind of interesting one its
sequel over JSON so I have Jason
structures actually stored in the
database but I can query it with a
sequel syntax so this could be good in
those cases where you don't want to use
a different kind of completely different
API and you have developers that are
familiar with sequel then they would be
familiar with this kind of query
capability so we're seeing example this
here in a second the second one is
documents so this is kind of your
traditional oh jiggle oh we're back so
this is your just document database to
be your just traditional like no sequel
database that you're kind of probably
familiar with with the document database
though one of the things they did was
instead of inventing their own API and
their own querying language for it and
instead they said okay what's the most
popular document database out there
[ __ ] okay so what if we just implement
the [ __ ] API and protocol on top of our
document database instead of inventing a
completely new one and so that's what
they have here's the model is the
document structure inside the database
and then the querying capabilities and
the interaction capabilities are through
a specific kind of API in this case
MongoDB so what that means is that I can
actually use any kind of [ __ ] client to
connect to cosmos DB and it just works
most of the time almost all the time
there are some things that aren't
supported for some of these API is that
doesn't support every single possible
operation so that's something to look at
but what was really nice for our client
is they were using MongoDB through their
own hosted instance and said we want to
move to the cloud and so they literally
just changed some connection properties
and the application just started working
now with all their data in the cloud now
this is not actually [ __ ] database
MongoDB hosts in the cloud it is Azure
cosmos DBS special data structures and
fail out and I'll failover and
replication structures behind the scenes
so they're not just hosting MongoDB for
you what they're doing is providing an
API to connect to it to and query with
and MongoDB they also support columnar
through the cassandra api tables which
was a little weird for me as well so
those of you that are using agile teaser
table storage which is anyone using that
i've met like one person that's ever
touched as your table storage and so
what that allows you to do is instead of
having your Azure tables Azure table
storage stored and as your table storage
instead those tables can be stored
inside of Azure cosmos DB and now inside
of Azure cosmos DB you get the global
scale that that provides which isn't
provided inside of your table storage
itself and again all you have to do is
point your connection to Azure cosmos to
be instead of the other thing and it'll
just start working and finally it also
supports graph models so instead of just
individual documents that are separate
from each other we injures to the
concept of connections between
individual nodes and we can again query
this using the most popular way of
querying graph api's which is a an
interesting query language called
gremlin this is the one I had actually
the most trouble with we try to move our
own hosted graph that was inside an old
machine inside a shirt which is like the
most expensive stupid thing to do is to
do VMs and Azure we tried to move our
neo4j instance into this but it turns
out that we were using a lot of advanced
query capabilities that aren't yet
supported so that the gremlin one what
you'll see is some of these query api's
they have a subset of the chorong api's
that are actually actually exists out
there so you do have to carefully
consider what kind of querying
capabilities you need before just
jumping straight in and say right we're
just absolutely going to do this now a
cosmos TB actually started out as a j''r
document DB so as your document DB was
this document database in the cloud it
was built on top of a lot of the pieces
that Azure cosmos to be had and then as
those extra pieces and Azure cosmos TV
which wasn't released yet became more
more feature-rich
than Azure document DB just got folded
into cosmos DB as just one of the
Aquarian models available for you now
one of the big questions I get about
cosmos TV is why should I use it
should I just use it because I'm
interested in doing some kind of no
sequel in the cloud well maybe but when
it comes to
the capabilities of Cosmos TV especially
with its scale it is priced accordingly
so you may you may start off using an
simpler version or a more free version
and some other hosting model and then as
you need some more scale than to go to
Azure cosmos TV now one of the most
interesting things about it of course is
its rich modeling capabilities you don't
have to just do document database you
don't have to just do one of these
models instead you can pick and choose
what model is appropriate for you now
again this is scoped to the database so
you have to pick up front like which
model makes sense for you but again in
general I don't really find people get
confused about what kind of database
they need but it is nice that they have
the the major ones support out there
whether it's key value document database
colander or graph and they're adding
more so the graph one for example is new
in the last six months all built on top
of the internal structures of azure
cause magic cosmos TV the other major
reason you want to use it is its global
scale so some of the announcements even
this week at build expanded its scale
capabilities so if you need applications
that do truly need global scale then you
would start to look at some kind of no
sequel solution because those are the
kinds of databases that can provide this
sort of global reach so as your cosmos
to be was built for those applications
in mind so when you go to the website
and it says like what are the kind of
use cases you'll see they'll talk about
things like mobile applications
manufacturing systems where I have this
kind of global global reach anything
that needs to reach on a global scale is
something you should start looking at as
your cosmos DB as a potential solution
now there are a lot of existing
solutions out there for these kinds of
models and so yes you can use any of
these existing solutions what we ran
into though is that when we picked one
of these solutions out of the box
we were now wholly responsible for the
server that's hosting these this
software and a lot of the software is
best run on Linux and most of my
customers have no idea how to manage
Linux servers like they know how to use
a macbook right and run bash commands
but it's something completely different
to run Linux servers at scale so
they just didn't want to have to
maintain their own servers and their own
systems and have to learn how to manage
these solutions they just wanted to have
the capabilities that these databases
provided but not have to carry all the
burden of hosting these so cosmos DB
provides this platform as a service
offering that says you can still have
these kinds of databases but now we will
take care of all the hosting and
management and then you just get this
nice lovely API to call to talk to now
for for those of you that already have
existing systems and existing databases
it turns out you can already do some
kinds of no sequel in those databases so
you can do and actually for the last ten
years you can do kind of schema list
systems inside a data sequence erver so
for example you can have XML columns
right that's a thing you can put XML
inside a sequel server and query off of
that you can also output things as XML
so yeah we've had no sequel in sequel
server for a long time right you just
have it as XML well I don't think anyone
I've never really met anyone that's
actually done this other than some
people that decided to directly connect
store procedures to web soap web
services and they could just output the
XML directly but for most of my
customers they've never touched anything
like this now some new features inside a
sequel server
starting with 2014 I think are probably
2012 are the ability to directly store
JSON objects inside of the database so
for these it has a kind of funny syntax
so you had this kind of weird looking
Jason values and jason or is json
methods here but i can use use json
queries to be able to look for
individual values inside a single column
that is storing a JSON blob so instead
of what I used to do would be to
serialize JSON and stored in a like a
byte array or something like that it's
like sequel server but you can't query
that and so now sequel server exposes
directly the ability to store JSON as
values inside the database and it's
first-class querying and selection
capabilities out of there so if you have
an existing system
and you need some kind of some things
that are scheme ulis I would look at
these kind of things first because it's
much easier just to use whatever you
have already and then to introduce
something that now is going to have to
involve procurements because we have to
ask procurements for the money to be
able to purchase and deploy as your
cosmos TV so that's something I would
look at first is can we just get away
with storing things inside of our own
database before we start looking outside
and going to something more something
more complicated now for scale a sequel
server does support the idea of failover
clusters so if a single single the
master or the primary goes down then it
could failover to a secondary and the
more expensive versions of sequel server
support the idea of an cluster failover
machines so that if a primary goes down
and then another machine goes down there
are multiple ones that it could fail
over - this is like super expensive
though
it's like the most expensive checkbox
and the installer no it's a man like you
check the box for the sequel server
always on it's like you better have your
wallet open because the Microsoft
licensing P will be right at your door
ready to charge you for this sort of
stuff so you do get this failover
capabilities but the other thing we run
into is that these replicas have to be
very close to that original instance
which somewhat defeats the purpose of
having global scale if all of the
machines have to be very close to each
other what I want is to not have to
worry about a single server going down
or RAC going down or potentially a whole
server farm going down or entire
location going down I can still have my
application up and running especially
for mission-critical applications or
ones that do have to reach that global
scale now they have relaxed the
licensing somewhat on this so if you do
need this always-on capability it now is
supporting the standard version so it's
still expensive but not so so expensive
but we want something that can failover
to multiple machines that's again only
the enterprise version which again you
have to have your wallet out to be able
to pay for that kind of thing so with
our group when we moved from going from
sequel to MongoDB and eventually to
Azure cosmos DB we had a lot of we had a
lot of bumps in the road to be able to
make that transition now
in transitioning from sequel we were
able to effectively cut out the DBAs
from the conversation that did come to
bite us later on when we needed actually
report out of the system and found out
that MongoDB charges for reporting oops
probably should have looked at early on
but sequel is modeled very differently
from any kind of no sequel offerings so
in a typical modeling session we have we
start to look at the the major nouns in
the system say these going to be the
tables so in this case gonna have like a
product table and then I look to see
what that thing is related to so it's
going to be related to in this case I
have categories so it's can be related
to categories some model information
descriptions for translations off
cultures things like that and one of the
nice things about this model is that
it's a very flexible query model I can
start at the product level I can go out
to one direction I can start from a
category level and start to pull in
other products so it provides a very
flexible way of querying over my data
that's both a good thing and a bad thing
especially those of you that have used
RMS and then also I've used RMS in the
presence of a database administrator and
then they see the sequel that's being
generated and they come in yellow angry
things take away your ORM and then only
give you stored procedures from their
announced so while this provides a lot
of flexibility it also comes with a lot
of responsibility to really understand
what you're doing behind the scenes the
other thing that we found with this sort
of model is doesn't really enforce a lot
of constraints that we were wanting to
so we wanted to make sure for example
that when you add an order and a line
item that the the line items total
always bubbles up to the order so you
can do that pretty easily in code but
it's difficult to model that kind of
relationship inside of a database really
little thing like triggers and stuff
like that what I'm just looking at it
there's nothing telling me that those
kind of constraints are in place it's
just kind of a big mess of tables and
then you have to figure out like what is
the right direction for me to start
traveling in these different
relationships here so in a no sequel
scenario we model things now much
differently instead of having things
that we can join to we have to make sure
that all the information that we're
interested in has to be stored inside of
that one document but inside that
document we have now a much richer
data structure that we can work with so
in this case I've got an example of an
order stored as a JSON document inside a
sequel server or inside of a inside of
Cosmos t-beam now if I was modeling an
order typically I would have an order
table and then I'd probably have a
customer table to link to to say this
customer is this customer purchased this
order that way if the customer has
multiple orders I only have one customer
in the database instead of that
duplicated throughout my orders and if I
have line items in my order of course
I'll have another line items table so I
will have the line item plus the product
ID of the product they're purchasing and
so in order to get the full view of a
single order I'd have to query like in
this case let's see the order table the
customer table the line items table the
product table at least four tables that
have to join together to be able to get
this view now most systems that I work
but that's that's a that's on the way
low end of joins that have to do to be
able to show some information on screen
typically I see queries with like 8 9 10
joints to be able to get the information
and be able to view on the screen now
for a lot of sequel server instances
that's not that terrible you can always
just throw more money and at the server
to make it beefier and beefier but for
this one when everything is on that
single record I only have to make one
connection make one query it never turns
out one single result and not to connect
to anything else inside the database so
that entire model is stored in one
single record inside the database I
don't have to go out and pull in a lot
of other pieces of information
everything's stored inside of it now
because it's JSON jason supports complex
structures like having a customer object
with child property so I can go order
that customer that first-name ordered a
customer last name I don't have to first
denormalize that to store it into a flat
table so if I try to store this in one
record and sequel server I would have
like a customer first name and a
customer last name if I want it to be at
to be on one single row I can also have
arrays inside of my object as well for
these one-to-many scenarios and again I
don't have to do a join to be able to
get this information everything is
pulled back when I pull back this one
record I don't have to go out and pull
out other records from other places
if I need to connect to other places for
some other reason I can still store the
keys as just individual data values
inside of my document so in this case
I'm storing the Product ID for the
products for this individual line items
just directly inside of my record here
and then if I want to go pull out that
Product ID I'll pull up the product
related to this I can't do that inside
of this database I'd have to make
additional calls to be able to get those
individual records so this something to
keep in mind is that when I'm designing
these kinds of data structures I'm
designing this so that I only need to
make that one call to get all the
information I need and if I do to make
other calls that I understand that
there's a penalty for that I have to
make additional calls to get those
additional pieces of information so no
joints inside of here whatsoever there
are projection capabilities but you
can't join two documents together that's
just not how it's designed so you have
to build everything inside of this one
record so you have to really understand
what you're designing what you're
building to make sure that this document
is designed correctly this is one of the
big things that we ran into in our first
first foray into document databases we
designed a lot of them incorrectly at
first and it was difficult for us to
migrate those data structures to new
data structures over time because it's
schema-less this it could be difficult
to say well what what is all what are
although the bad records in my system
that have the incorrect kind of data
structures and what are all the good
ones well that's not that easy to do yet
to literally query over all this are the
items in the system so something to keep
in mind the schema list doesn't mean
there's no schema in your system the
schema exists it's in your application
not in the database so something we
found out the hard way now there are
cases that we do want to duplicate some
of that data so in this case I don't
want to have to go back to the product
the product database to be able to get
this information just to show the order
on the screen so there were cases we
really looked at immutable data that is
like data that doesn't change over time
instead of us needing to go back to the
original systems if that data is only
all
once then we found I was okay for us to
go ahead and include that information in
our document I'll be super careful about
this because you really have to
understand if that other information
changes do I need to have it updated
here and if it does need to be updated
here then that's when you would never
want to do this if you have to have the
data updated in both places
then just don't don't do this kind of
thing but for something like product
information where we saw that that data
is really just written once and never
changed again then it was okay for us to
like cache it locally inside of her
document here and that way we don't have
to go back to the product catalog system
which was still a sequel server database
so the other thing we've noticed is that
just because I am copying the data does
not mean it's actually duplicating the
data over time we'll have an example of
this so I worked at an ecommerce system
for a while and the overall ecommerce
value stream if you will was you go
online you shop for some items and we
call this the catalog when you want to
purchase an item you put the item into
your cart so you say Add to Cart so
something like a product price we'd
start out with okay I see the product
price as $24.99 and they add an either
add the item to my cart and now it shows
up my make heart as $24.99
when I hit checkout I now go to an order
screen and I see again that price there
$24.99 and my order price and then
finally what it gets down to fulfillment
and billing they'll see that same price
again to know how much to charge me
eventually
now what happens in this scenario when
the product price changes all the way up
in the catalog side does that mean we
need to change the prices for every
single system that had that product
price as part of it did these other
systems actually have to go back to the
catalog to get product pricing for every
step along the way well no they don't do
that in fact you think probably think
it'd be really weird or in honestly
infuriating if I'm sitting in my cart
and the product price changes and the
price changes in my carts that's
probably something you not but you don't
want to have happen to your customers so
in this case even though the data was
copied from location to location that
didn't mean that admit the same thing
over time
so when data moves between service bound
and when it crosses that service
boundary sometimes its meaning can
change and so in this case the price we
had along every step of the way was not
product price anymore
we had a catalogue price we had a cart
price we had an order price and then
finally we had the billing price or the
fulfillment price so this was the amount
we actually charge the customer because
then any step along the way if I want a
reason about the price at that point in
time I don't care about what the catalog
says today I care about it what the
price was or is in this step of the
process
so in this case even though we were
copying the data it didn't mean the same
thing anymore it didn't mean the product
price anymore it was the cart price the
order price or the fulfillment price
didn't mean the same thing now I did
have a customer that didn't like this
they saw this as duplicate data and they
said we have to we can't have been
duplicated data to the system that's the
bane of our existence is duplicate data
so what we'll do is normalize everything
to some other in normal form because
there there are normal forms passed
third normal form by the way you didn't
even had the privilege of stealing those
kind of databases so how do I get the
price then and my order if the product
price can change and the way they try to
solve that was to put active dates on
all these fields to say price as of this
specific date so when I joined from my
order back to the catalog to get the
product price because we can't duplicate
it I had to pass in the order date to
know what the price should be as of that
point in time two months ago or I could
just copy the price from location
location realize that it's actually
changing its meaning it's no longer the
product price it's something else
and then everyone is happy well except
for that one DBA but you learn to learn
to live with it one of the thing we
found with with sequel databases is they
do support this concept of relationships
so in this case I've got relationships
between product and product photo and
product model on product subcategory and
unit measure but if I want to get
information about those relationships
that's really difficult to do so in this
case I have links between these things
but I
have any information about those links
so in more complex scenarios where I
want to include information about the
relationships
that's when sequel starts to break down
and I especially see this when I have a
graph of things and I want to relate
them to each other you can do those in
the sequel server there's things like
common table expressions does anyone
like canoe me do that at the top of
their head buyers will have a little
quiz after class we'll see if that's
actually true so you can do kind of
recursive joins and funny joins to build
graphs of things but it's does it
doesn't come back to the graph and you
want to query those relationships it's
pretty difficult inside a sequel server
so you wind up creating tables to
represent those relationships and now
your joints become really weird and ugly
and you start to have lots of weird
cardinality and lots more rows of return
because it can't really represent the
different nodes versus different edges
very well inside this one single kind of
structure so you see these kinds of
relationships a lot and things like
social media apps right you have
Facebook or LinkedIn that says who
you're connected to who you're friends
with and then you have information that
could be then stored along with that
relationship as well so if I want to
query those relationships like if we go
to LinkedIn and you search somebody and
it says like you're three steps away
from that person that's best answered
with a graph database as opposed to a
sequel database yeah so I don't build a
lot of social media apps personally I
try not to use them except for things
like beer check-in apps things like that
but what I do do a lot is track history
of things and probably the best example
I have to be able to track history and
make these connections is amazon.com and
if you go to amazon.com website just
look at any kind of product page to
start to scroll down you can start to
see the other kinds of information they
can be pulled out by having connections
between different things for example
things like frequently bought together
so I'm looking at this one this is the
the amplify which I highly recommend as
a really awesome home networking device
and it told me that when someone buys
this thing people frequently buy this
other thing now try to imagine how you
would answer that question inside a
sequel server that is you have orders
and line items and you have to go
traverse like all the okay go find all
the line items and then go find all
related items but then then then do a
weightings it says make sure I count how
many times these different items are
purchased together and roll those up and
find me the top one that is going to be
shown here like you can probably write
that query but it's not going to return
very quickly so a Garth database who is
connecting orders and line items and
saying when someone buys this product
they also buy this other product and
then start to include like how many
times people bought these products
together then it's a very easy query to
return back from a graph database I can
even track behaviors for customers who
are just going through the going through
the website so instead of orders in the
system things like if I'm looking at
this item
who else looked at it like what other
stuff are people looking at so as you
look at things inside of Amazon it's I
don't think it's tracking in the browser
because that's wrong right attraction on
the server and on the server it's
keeping track of what your overall
history is and says ok you looked at
this item you looked at this item you
looked at this item and then aggregates
for one item what are they all the other
stuff that people looked at and said
here are the top things that people have
looked at who also looked at whatever
you're looking at right now so I use
this quite frequently to say okay I'm
looking for this this product but
there's a lot of competing products I
don't really know which one's the right
one but this will tell me what are some
other related products and also can tell
me the price and reviews so I can see
that hey oh this other one is actually
reviewed much better by a lot more
people so maybe I should go look at that
one
instead again I you can do this kind of
query in sequel server but it is very
very difficult and expensive and then
finally have something like customers
who bought this item also bought so the
first one was frequently bought together
so that is in a single purchase what do
people typically buy that together this
one is looking at order history it says
when people buy this item what are their
orders do those customers have and what
commonality do those different orders
from those different customers have so
this case we have customers who bought
thing also would go on to buy this old
switch I guess I find that highly
dubious maybe they started with a switch
and like ooh that's I don't want one of
those things I want to I want to just
Wi-Fi so let me do that
but again trying to try to do this
inside a relational database it's just a
very difficult thing to do so as you get
these like really weird marketing
questions about hey can we can we can
run a query to do this you're like okay
we can do it once but that's it if we
want to do this every time someone looks
at something on a screen then we have to
build something special to be able to
take care of this so these kind of
queries just absolutely blow up the
overall sequel model and you wind up
having to go to other more rich models
with the graph database now this is when
I'm when my my customer realized that
sequel wasn't gonna work for them and
started to move toward graph databases
this is probably the biggest transition
that they had because the query
capabilities inside a graph databases
are way way different than anything else
I've ever used it uses a special
language called gremlin to be able to
execute graph queries and gremlin is a
language written in groovy which is a
was the actual programming language not
a right and so in this kind of graph
database I don't just have individual
records by themselves I don't have just
the individual record that has all the
data I don't I don't have to have just
that instead I start to connect those
different nodes together so in this case
they've got different people with
different connections and those
connections can also have names so
instead of just saying like this is
related to that well how is it related
what is that relationship there so in
this case I get things like Marco knows
Josh or created IOP Java something and
Peter also created that as well so I can
have different nodes with different
kinds of relationships and then also
have values and attributes on those
relationships as well so as I traverse
the graph I don't have to just follow
connections I can also look for
connections with certain values and
certain distinctions and certain types
to be able to figure out how these
things are related to each other and the
final thing that we ran into
another somewhat difficult transition
was transitioning from transactions in
sequel to transactions in no sequel
transactions in no sequel for a lot of
no sequel databases it's it's more kind
of a like optional sort of thing that
people do like oh yeah we kind of do
transactions somewhat but they really
don't really do that many transactions
but transactions and sequels start with
start with this write acid which is
atomic consistent interesting and
durable I have something I forget and it
all comes back from a series of papers
written like 35 years ago or so so in an
acid database and a one that supports
these kind of transactions you can do
things like this you can begin a
transaction you can do multiple sets of
operations and then you can either
commit or rollback that operation when
you commit that operation either all of
the changes go or none of the changes go
and the idea haim behind the deep heart
and acid says that if partial changes
happen it'll roll back the other changes
as well so something happens like in
between here it'll roll back those
intermediate changes and finally you can
actually roll back the entire
transaction as well to say undo all of
these changes so what do you typically
do when you start to look at okay this
is no sequel database I want to use it
does this thing support transactions
that actually this comes up on the FAQ
for Azure cosmos DB says does a source
port transaction yes it does with
JavaScript store procedures and triggers
combining my three favorite things
javascript and stored procedures and
javascript triggers
that's one of those legs you just tell
me to go F myself now the reason why
they do this of course is that the data
structures inside of Cosmos DB are json
documents
so that's JavaScript so why not use the
language of the data structures as the
language to do these procedures and then
finally why do store procedures for
actual transactions that if I want to
modify multiple records at the same time
well I need a
that code executed as close to the data
as possible and the only way you can do
that is to put that code in the database
via a stored procedure now I won't show
you one of these things because I can't
put them on the screen they're so big
about how to do these kind of stored
procedures but they do exist we we
looked at them and saw how difficult
they were going to be to use and then we
also knew that if we had anything called
a store procedure someone in the DBA
land would be listening on our emails
put their head up and say ooh now I can
help to write stored procedures for
every single point of data access so we
don't want to do that we said okay yes
this is possible for us but we want to
treat this as a last resort so what can
we do otherwise so one of the problems
of doing a transaction between two
different records is I don't know if
those two different records are
necessarily on the same machine anymore
and something like cosmos would be I
don't care where that individual
document is stored
if document a is on this machine and
document B is on that machine I don't
care at all because I'm not only
querying one document at a time but now
if I wanted to do a transaction between
those two different documents now I need
to coordinate those two activities and I
could do that be a store procedure
that's executed like a highly
coordinated activity or I could start to
look at what does it mean to not do
these kinds of transactions and this
kind of transaction where I'm having to
deal with two different two different
operations are also known as distributed
transactions because I'm transacting
between two different records on two
different machines so there's this great
paper by a fellow Pat Helland who
basically he was on the sequel server
team and he actually built the
distributed transaction stuff inside of
sequel server and then he had this
epiphany when he moved to either Amazon
or was it Salesforce or he's like oh you
can't do this at these cloud scale
operations because I can't put the
entire world in transaction so what
would it mean to move away from these
sort of things well I only had these
individual records I can deal with how
do I coordinate activities between these
two different records well his brilliant
idea was to use some kind of messaging
to transact between these two pieces so
the idea is that I have a transaction
between these two entities instead of
trying to mutate both at once i mutate
the primary one and store inside of it a
message it says i also want to mutate
this other one over there so that way
the right only happens with that sending
entity at one point in time and then
later on when i message finally gets
delivered to the receiving entity then
finally i can go ahead and perform the
operation in that second one now there
are some problems here my transaction
can only be around one single document
at a time or one single entity so how do
I deal with like taking a message from
one entity and giving it to the other
well I have to now keep track of these
conversations between entities so as
operations build up over time I keep
track of the things I've done with other
people so I'm receiving messages storing
them and keeping track of them so that
when I if I happen to receive the same
message again then I could say oh I've
already done that nothing to do so each
of these entities uses messaging but a
special kind of messaging in which the
messages are stored actually inside the
document itself and it uses internal
document messages to communicate to
other things now when we looked at this
we said that sounds awfully familiar
this idea that I have documents or
aggregates needed to communicate to
other documents or aggregates and if
you've been around domain-driven design
much this actually is a first level
concept inside that world and it's known
as domain of its domain events and what
I can do here is I have a single a
single document in this case I have some
order here and that order has all the
attributes of the order so it's got the
first name the customer information the
line items the price the total all that
sort of stuff isn't inside of there but
if I need to communicate to any other
entities instead of me doing that
directly I'll keep track of that
communication with an inbox in an outbox
an L boxes messages I want to give to
other entities so I would need to do
something to suck that thing over there
so I have a message on my outbox over
there and the inbox are messages that
I've received and processed so I when I
get a message that says I need to do
this thing then I look at my inbox and
say have already done that thing
they've already done that thing they say
nothing to do nothing to do if I haven't
done that thing yet then I'll go ahead
and perform whatever operation I need to
do I will add that message to my inbox
and perform one save operation that
writes my entire document and I'm done
now as I communicate to these external
external records then I'll just delete
my records out of my outbox and we found
this worked really well for the document
database so the messages themselves
could just be other JSON objects and as
long as I kept track of what the
communication I had then it was really
pretty straightforward for me to
interact with other aggregates without
having to do something like a store
procedure inside of the database well I
haven't found any kind of tools or
frameworks that do this kind of thing
out of the box so to speak so we didn't
have to write a lot of infrastructure
code to be able to support this kind of
model but in the end we found it was
worth it because I no longer had a care
about oops some developer accidentally
tried to write to two documents and once
what happens to the second document it
just goes away
oops so with this model we were able to
pretty easily interact with multiple
documents at once and not have to worry
about the transaction side-effects
speaking of transactions even the
consistency models inside of Cosmos DB
are much different than sequel server so
sequel server has these consistency
models that basically protect your
information and most people don't
actually use the highest level of
transactions the serializable most
people use things like repeatable read
or we committed snapshot is somewhat
expensive so that's optimistic
concurrency support it inside a sequel
server but it is have an expense
associated with that in terms of
resources so these people can get away
with repeatable reads so that I can I
can read my own rights but I won't see
necessarily other people's rights yet
until their transactions are done one of
the things we found is that most of the
time our transactions aren't actually
acid that is to the letter of what acid
is so this was a this was a report from
Peter Bela Bayliss who looked to see
what are all the actual consistency
models supported by the major relational
databases out there and one of the
default ads
and what we see is that actually most
databases don't even support acid
transactions that is serializable
transactions most have some lower
version of it and then most as well
don't even have serializable as the
default option because serializable is
actually really expensive to do it can
block reads from that row so you want to
be very very careful in doing these kind
of operations so cosmos DB has a similar
kind of concept there's something that's
more tuned for cloud scale operations so
they have a tunable consistency model
that basically goes from strong from a
strong consistency tonight.we
consistency but they call it eventual
consistency and a strong consistency
that means that I'm guaranteed to have
the most recent version of an item I
never read any still items ever now for
systems that I'm always updating maybe
that's something I really want to have
like if there's some precious resource
that everyone has to have the most
updated version that I can do that one
typically people do something like a
session based consistency level which
means I can read my own rights rights
will follow a previous read and then
it's just like most normal operations
that's pretty same default and so I
think like 80% of people use just
session level consistency that just says
for the context of this connection I
expect in that inside that connection
that everything should be consistent for
those communications now if there are
other connections and other sessions
other people are doing they won't
necessarily see what I'm doing but at
least I can see what I'm doing and
that's what most people really want is
to be able to see the work that they're
doing and not really care about what
other work other people are doing so I
want to switch over to a demo to show
you some of the capabilities of your
Cosmos DB so I'm gonna first just go
through just a little example of what
it's like to actually create one of
these resources inside of Azure cosmos
DB and switch to do
it okay so I will go ahead and create a
new resource and this will be a cosmos
TV one right there
and let's call it something good and
this one I'll use the document db-api so
it's called and you see Minnesota 2018
mom go and the AP I'm going to choose
again I have to pick something here so
I'm going to pick the MongoDB API I will
use an existing resource group that way
it's super easy to delete all these
expensive things when I'm done and then
here's some other interesting checkboxes
you can do you can enable geo redundancy
which means that my data will be stored
on multiple different regions across the
globe and then finally down here this is
this this is the thing that was
announced just recently at build like
Monday or Tuesday is multi master that
is if the master node goes down the
client doesn't know about it will
automatically failover to another node
and I can start writing to that other
node with it but the other one I can
read from multiple nodes but I won't
necessarily be able to write to multiple
ones and this one I can actually write
to multiple nodes so when that one node
goes down it will automatically failover
to another one
there a lot of academic papers behind
the work behind how that happens behind
the scenes so I'd encourage you to go to
Microsoft's documentation on this
because it's really well done and really
well written on how this actually
happens but I'm gonna turn that off
because we're not gonna turn that on
because this is another expensive
checkbox that I want to check right now
and this one it's a preview feature so
you actually have to say I would like
this they don't have to turn on by
default okay all right so while this is
going some of the other things that we
found working with working with cosmos
TV going from [ __ ] and then going to
cosmos TV is a lot of the client api's
work just fine so for MongoDB for
example there are already existing
dotnet client api's to be able to work
with it and Luna the only difference for
us was a connection string to be able to
say point from this to that other thing
and we were good to go the problems we
did run into and we didn't run to a few
problems is that MongoDB API does
support the concept of updates inside of
a query so I can say do like a for each
on these things and do this little
update for each of those so it has this
atomic operation inside of the database
so there's more advanced features of
these api's that are atomic write
operations inside of the database
I found that none of the API is really
support that they want you to use the
client API to do that not a query API
inside of the database it's just too
complicated so we did have to fix those
to do that kind of work in code as
opposed to submitting a query inside of
the server itself should have known in
Azure talk nothing was gonna have oh
whoa it works okay this is
congratulations you did the thing so
some of the interesting things we can do
as part of this is we can actually
download some of these can actually let
you download existing sample
applications to be able connect to it
it'll give us a connection string so I
would literally just copy this and put
in it to my [ __ ] clients connection
string and I'm I'm good to go
some of the other ones I found actually
give you nice quick starts so in this
one for example let me go to the data
explorer they give you an ability to
actually query things directly inside of
the azure console here so in this case
I'm executing and this this is yes I'm
just returning back all the items inside
of my database here and so I've got an
array of items that says here's this
product here's this other product and
here's an a link between those two
products here's another existing one I
had going on and this one executes as a
gremlin query that
really funny thing to be able to connect
things together and so as I look at the
difference nodes and values inside of
here I can see that over on the right
has here all the edges associated with
it so I'm looking at bin and then it's
connected to robin via this nose target
so looks like Ben knows Robin okay to go
to Robin then I should see the other
direction that I am the source of it
that bin knows me it's really small so I
can zoom in nope that didn't do the
desired thing so gives you a way to to
play able to play around with queries
directly inside of the browser if you're
going to load up some other kind of
querying tool capability now all these
different kinds of databases do have
kind of standard querying tools
available for you so you can just like
this one for example there is a gremlin
console you can go to connect to this
and execute gremlin queries same with
[ __ ] you can go to the [ __ ] console
for Cassandra there's their own console
as well alright so I want to show an
actual example of me trying to build an
application as well so in this case what
I've done as I built a ecommerce
application to show the capabilities of
the document database
now this e-commerce application has two
parts one is the catalog to be able to
browse the different items in the store
let me go ahead and run this now the
catalog side I actually just pulled from
adventure works you know that old demo
database and Microsoft put out that show
you how to build relational databases I
didn't feel like inventing my own with a
bunch of dummy data so I just pulled
theirs and this is what they have here
so up at the top I've got the list of
product categories I can go click one
and it shows me the list of
subcategories and then finally I can
view the list of items I can add these
individual items to the cart so you see
over I'm going to write it's filling up
my carts I can oh I can also view one of
these individual items and they also add
that item to my cart as well so looking
at
those different pieces are put together
I can go to my different products pages
the list of products is not that
interesting but one thing you will
notice here is that I have to actually
do this include because I'm the going
from product category to product
subcategory because I'm showing these
two items I have to do and include that
will perform that join for me so that's
not too bad
what about listing products well in this
one I'm starting from a subcategory and
then showing product details to be able
to add the product show the product
information so in this case I'm going
product subcategory and then joining in
the product information finding the one
that's just that one single product
subcategory again that's not too bad
right like just one two mini they're not
too bad it's the show one where things
start to get kind of interesting I had
to join multiple tables down so in this
case in order for me to show the
description on the screen I have to get
the product information then after
joined to the product model and then to
the product model product description
culture and then finally to the product
description table to actually pull out
the product description for the culture
that I'm looking at on the screen so one
two three four joints to be able to show
this on the screen right there what you
get it's like oh that's not too bad but
I'm just showing this one piece of
information as this screen gets more
complicated that's when I start to see
the joins explode my system and again I
can keep throwing the money the money at
that single server to make it good
faster and faster but it does reach an
upper limit where this kind of this kind
of approach doesn't work anymore so
let's see how I did the actual ordering
part so let me go back to my cart I'm
going to hit o my cart went away
I picked the in memory session and I
think it just goes away after time okay
so I hit checkouts and now I'm looking
at some order details
so let's look to see what the checkout
actually did so in my cart controller
when I actually perform the checkout so
we have right here so first what I'll do
is get the cart information for me I
could have stored this in something else
as your specific but I was lazy so I
just stored
inside of session state so it's just
getting the cart out of session and then
from there I'm going to store that order
inside of Azure cosmos TV but instead of
me storing an order with order line
items and a separate customers all
different things and instead I'm storing
it as one single item one single
document one single record and so that
right here is this order request the
order request includes
in this case this is just dummy customer
information whatever and then also
include the light items now the light
items will copy over some of the
information again the information it
copies over is the information that
either doesn't change over time so it's
it's immutable or it's it's data that
actually changes meaning as I go from
one overall step to them to the next so
in this case I'm copying over the the
product ID so if I ever want to get that
original product information that's good
then I have the quantity from the cart
of course I need that I'm I'm pulling
over the list price because then I don't
want changes in the price affecting my
order whatsoever and I'm also pulling
over the product name just because
that's something that doesn't change so
it's an easy thing to do then I will
call into Azure cosmos DB and I just
have a kind of a simple wrapper on top
of this this is using a repository
pattern and that's implementation it's a
pretty straightforward call I use this
create document async and then builds up
some information about exactly which
database and collection to put this
thing into and then finally the item
itself is just a dotnet object so that
Dino object will be serialized into JSON
when it goes into the database so pretty
much the in terms of what data
structures it supports just all the
normal things that new and soft jason
supports just don't get cute or clever
just keep things simple and then
everything will work out okay okay so at
this point my my order is inside of
cosmos TV but notice there is no like
begin transaction begin session a commit
transaction once I make that call right
there my order is inside cosmos TV
so from that points I need to go ahead
and clear the items in my carts put that
empty cart back into session and then
finally I'll go ahead and redirect to
the show order page for that order that
just came back this documents came back
with that ID so I can say redirect to
that order with that specific ID now
when I go look at my order inside of
Cosmos TV they can see what it created
that was in the right place where is
mine there's data Explorer okay so
here's my collection or the database of
order requests and then from there how
the collection of items so a database
can have multiple collections you can
kind of think of minutes tables I don't
want to store or just everything inside
of one collection because I can't reason
about it so in this case I just had
order requests as a top-level database
and the order request items as just that
one collection I have as part of that
then I want to see all the orders that
exist right here it's turning back for
results I have four existing orders and
this one that I just did was a total of
three three 99.99 so oh that's this one
right here and it said I purchased one
single mountain bike with this Product
ID with the quantity of 1 and of course
everything's stored as at single array
of items and my custom formation again
is a more complex structure so I can
have customer that first name customer
that last name and then finally there's
some other junk that's internal database
stuff they don't really need to worry
about so you can't name things those so
if you really wanted to name property
underscore self you can't I don't know
if you would want to do that but there
are some reserve properties that we have
there so one thing I should note here is
that I actually picked the sequel
version of the API so up here is a
sequel query so I can do something like
select star from C where C dots
let's see status equals
zero-zero this tell me it returns three
different orders I can look for the
status of two which means it's been
approved and I only see one order being
returned so back in my application I can
actually approve the order so let me go
ahead and click approve and now you can
see yep
the status went from new to approved and
if I rerun my query I'll see that's yeah
and now I have two orders approved and
down here is my second approved order
right there now we're turning this item
back in the screen for showing the
actual order I have over in the order
show order page here I'm using the same
document database document DB repository
and then when it returns the item it
just does get item and DC realizes that
that item from JSON into the strongly
typed order request objects and now I
have this much richer or to request
object to deal with so I've got all the
line items the status the total the
customer information I can now show that
on the screen so if you want to include
that information I can do order or dots
customer that first name so it's still
strongly typed
with schema-less so I have some object
that does represents what is going to be
put into the database but if I want to
change that object over time I don't
have to do schema updates to do so I can
just add new properties get it serialize
I'm good to go now I will say that one
of the things we did right into is we
actually did one point at one point time
need migrations for our database because
we needed to change the structure of
what was in there
and there's really nothing out there
that is for migrations of document
databases there's nothing that let that
helps you with this specific with this
problem here of what happens when I do
something like add customer middle name
what about all the existing records with
customer little name well do I just
ignore it if it doesn't exists I didn't
make sure the D serialization doesn't
lose that information if it's a required
information what I do with all the
existing stuff so all that kind of stuff
we had before it's those kind of
problems still exist for us we just have
to do them now in code to be able to fix
those scenarios so that was our really
our last lesson we learned was the even
though there was no schema the schema
still existed it just moved to code as
opposed to being inside the database
itself so we still have all the problems
with schema changes over time but we'd
had to write up some of our own tooling
to be able to support that
so if you have more questions
Microsoft's website is fantastic for
this so I'd go I'd say start there first
because they have a lot of great
tutorials to be able to to to build it
just download samples and get going from
there in terms of pricing that is
another thing that I didn't try to go
through but read carefully how the
pricing works could is is very different
from other kind of offerings inside of
Asher and so that is the usually
limiting factor of why people don't use
cosmos DB is because they're just
running MongoDB locally and now they
want to go to cloud and they're like oh
wait that's this is for like globally
distributed applications and it's priced
accordingly so something else to keep in
mind otherwise if you have any questions
I'll be around afterwards otherwise
thank you very much and have a great
rest of the conference
and of course don't forget to rate the
session out there the red and yellow
ones are broken there they're not
working right now so just the grains
please